у тілі ось і на посадковий
бізнес-моделей отримавши на політику
цех головного мага заходу до українських
потужного активу приносимо ти сосунки про
значення криво ники в дар шпет преемство
їх не фінансову світлості проводили
опитування ору та приватизації town та модулі
планера страждання чиновниками захисну
допомогу євросоюз пройдусь їм німецькі
політики на радіоактивно розмір кови
вають треба треба німба хату мільярдну
допомогу українці екрані зігріти і їм
зручно і харчування хто розподіляти і
макоша the cave хоче сама стягнутися
рубає цю гроші берлін і виключаючи при
європейських значеннях наочно ніж для
каравані я бюджетами справні бачати
ранній анни косметичний реформи то
конкретні результати боротьби з
корупцією та про ітан donna за лижні
стіни до рибки ну-ка видом ство то
звали до не за реформи та суддівську
системи
офіційного берліну за опції тричі були
шаленим для українців перед харчуванням
малюки супроводу безвізового режиму
з євросоюзом та продовження обидва
скошування санте проти росії в тріумфуйте
в руку року просто сядь вже з вимагаєш
у таких diy конкретних перед злодії
панчохи а та захисту від України
менше муразі зі стану чирків та періодом
малих можна швидше в тому й вигляді
україни мудрість як він френсіс без ппц
ж засвітила тему України перейшла на
інший план поступившись свині у сирі
це проблемі біженці в Європі